-Welcome back. Hey, guys, if you
love seeing new inventions
and you love brilliant kids,
then you're really
going to love this.
That's right, it's time
for "Fallonventions."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Welcome to Fallonventions,
Jimmy Fallon's
night of invention.
-Now, I love inventions
and I'm okay with kids.
So we found some the best
and brightest kids out there,
and I think you are going to be
amazed at what we came up with.
So let's meet
our first inventor.
Come on over here, Riley.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Riley.
Hi, bud.
-Hi.
-Nice to see you.
Riley, what is your full name?
How old are you
and where are you from?
-I am Riley Shove,
I'm 12 years old,
and I'm from Manchester,
Connecticut.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being on the show.
Riley, what is your invention?
-My invention is the Play Box.
I love spreading out and playing
with my toys all over my house
but I really hate cleaning up
the mess.
-Yeah, me too.
-So this is the solution.
-So what do we have to do here?
Can I help you out?
-So we can start by making
a little mess with these toys.
-Okay.
Oh, yeah, I'm good at this.
Okay, good.
Looks like my office floor.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Spread them out a little bit.
-Okay.
-So then after you play a little
bit, you can then push
all the toys back into
the middle of the Play Box.
-Uh-huh.
-Then fold up the four flaps.
-Oh, I like this idea.
Oh, yeah, this is genius.
Okay, wait a second.
-Yeah.
-Yep, you're a genius.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, okay.
-Then you lift up
the side flaps.
-Of course you do.
-Turning it into a box.
-Yep, that's exactly right.
[ Audience oohs ]
You are an absolute -- You are
a billionaire, my friend.
I can't believe
I'm meeting you now.
When you go to space,
you gotta let me know, okay?
So I can come in your rocket.
Oh, my gosh. Did I do it right?
-Yeah.
-Look at that.
And now you have just a box,
you can just travel with.
-Now it's a box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This keeps all the toys inside,
and, as an added bonus, the side
clips can act as handles.
-Little handles right there.
Not bad.
This is brilliant.
I do love this.
Do you want to see an invention
I made?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You could be
a little more excited.
But get ready for this,
this is really cool.
This is unbelievable.
This is called a S'wig, okay?
Oh, geez.
Here's the way it works, okay?
It's a stylish wig, alright?
And concealed in the wig is
a drink bladder and a clear tube
that drops down from the wig
so you can take discreet sips
from the liquid hidden
in its pouch, in the wig.
It's perfect for sneaking in
drinks into the movie theater.
[ Laughter ]
Sporting events.
Kids' recitals.
Whatever you got to go,
you need to sneak a little --
have a little sip
and here you go.
It's just this easy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ah, that was refreshing.
-Okay.
-Thank you very much.
I can see you're impressed.
Thank you very much.
You can head over there.
I know I just blew her mind
right now.
She's like, "Yeah.
That toy box was something,
but this is next level."
Let's meet our next inventor.
Sarah. Come on over, pal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi.
-Hello.
-Jimmy. Hi, nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you too.
-Sarah, what is your full name?
How old are you
and where are you from?
-My name is Sarah Lamphere.
I'm from Wolcott, Connecticut.
-Welcome.
How old are you?
-I am 12 years old.
-12 years old.
And now, what is this invention?
What do you call this?
-I call this the Pet Puller.
It's a safe way to get cats out
of carriers.
-A safe way to get cats out of
carriers?
Can you explain that more to me?
-So, when I go to my mom's
veterinary clinic,
I sometimes see the technicians
struggling to get the cats
out of the carriers.
-Oh, yeah.
-Because the cats are scared,
they're scratching,
they're biting.
So I made a safe way
to get them out
without hurting
the technician or the cat.
-Okay, this is brilliant.
Can we see it in action?
Roots, can we get a gentle
drum roll please?
-Of course.
[ Soft drum roll ]
Look at that.
That is a brilliant idea,
and it just moves the back wall
back in.
[ Applause ]
This is fantastic.
Is this -- Is this your cat?
-No, this is not my cat.
-Oh, wow. What a good cat.
-I know.
-Do cats do this?
I thought this cat would
just dive out or something.
[ Laughter ]
It's very simple
and it's a brilliant invention.
I love this idea.
Congratulations.
I have an invention
that's also very simple
and brilliant as well.
I just want to show you.
Check this out.
It's called Over-Ear Earphones.
Now look.
-They look wonderful.
-Yeah, well, you don't even know
what they do yet.
Watch what they do.
This is -- Watch.
So basically, you put these on
and no one even knows that
you're wearing headphones.
-I wouldn't notice.
-Right?
[ Laughter ]
So you could be like at the
meeting or something like that
and everyone thinks
you're listening.
But really I'm actually just
jamming out to my favorite jams.
[ Laughter ]
Sarah, you still interested?
Alright.
-I think they look great.
-I couldn't hear what you said
but thank you, Sarah!
Thanks for coming on the show!
Why don't you head over there?
We'll get our next inventor
to come on over!
Come on over, Lucas. Lucas.
Where is Lucas?
Hey, bud. Nice to see you.
How are you? Lu-- Whoa.
That was interesting.
What are --
First of all, what is your --
Where are you from?
What's your full name? Sorry,
it's reversible, this thing.
It's great.
[ Laughter ]
How old are you?
Where are you from?
-My name is Lucas Kellogg,
I'm 14,
and I'm from Shelton,
Connecticut.
-That's good, man. A lot of
Connecticut love tonight.
What is your invention there,
bud? What do we have?
-My invention is
the Cold Clappers.
And I actually brought you
your own.
-What?
-There you go.
-You're a good man.
Look at these.
Cold Clappers?
Look, and that's my picture
on there right there.
[ Audience aws ]
That's very cool.
But what are Cold Clappers?
We're all enjoying this,
but what do Cold Clappers do?
-Both my brothers play hockey
and I always go to their games
and in the stands, everyone
is always wearing gloves
because the rinks get cold.
And so they try to cheer,
but they can't
when they're wearing gloves.
And so these go over your gloves
and it allows you
to cheer for your team.
[ Audience oohs ]
-I think this is kind of
a genius idea.
Can you show me how they work?
-So, you just put it
over your glove like that
and then you just start
clapping.
[ Laughter ]
Simple.
-Wow. Alright.
So what does it sound like?
Let's go.
[ Clapping ]
Oh, these are Cold Clappers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, I like this.
You can put any team logo
you want on there,
whatever, and then everyone is
clapping and clap for your team.
I love this. Hey, you know
what could be fun though?
This is kind of cool.
[ Laughter ]
Here's an extra S'wig.
You put on the S'wig.
Check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You want to try these on too?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah. Check these out.
This is going to be cool.
Look at this.
And now you got
your Cold Clappers, and then --
This is going to be bril.
I think we're
on to something here.
Ready, let's give
a little cold clap
to our inventors right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, everybody.
Come on back over here.
You can go in the front here
if you want, Lucas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do have one more thing
I want to show you.
We here at "The Tonight Show"
love supporting
smart, talented kids
like yourselves
and we want you to keep
exploring and creating
and changing the world.
So we're giving each of you
$5,000
to help further your education.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you, bud.
Lucas, you get a giant check.
Sarah, you get a giant check.
It's 5,000 bucks.
Not bad, Riley.
5,000 bucks right there
for you guys.
My thanks to
Riley, Sarah, Lucas.
Stick around.
We'll be right back!